[Música]
en julio del 2015 cuando llevaba sólo un
mes de vuelta a chile me junté con mi
entonces por primera vez compañeros de
teatro club social carlos a dedo y
eliana fórum an
creo que eso fue como la primera foto
que nos sacamos juntos
en ese momento ellos ya llevaban un
tiempo trabajando juntos y yo integraba
la compañía y nos propusimos crear un
nuevo proyecto y la dell y propuso que
tratará sobre inmigración al tiro a mí
la idea mismo sentido venía recién
llegando después de vivir tres años
afuera y venía llena de experiencias de
muchas dudas de experiencias mías y de
otros amigos que nos había tocado vivir
lejos de nuestro país y volvía a mi país
un país que en ese tiempo también había
cambiado que habían aparecido nuevos
colores nuevas caras nuevos peinados y
además estábamos en un contexto mundial
que también era particular y que yo creo
que similar al de ahora en que estaban
pasando fuertes crisis humanitarias
raíces de guerras como en siria por
ejemplo en donde imágenes como esta de
highland kurdi
recorrían todas las redes sociales
y en donde un entonces recién
presentándose candidato donald trump
hablaba de construir muros y ganaba
fuerza entre sus votantes planteando
esta idea de construir muros para que no
pudieran entrar inmigrantes en su país
donde en inglaterra de donde yo venía se
estaba hablando de un break sheet que lo
que planteaba era separarse del reino
del resto de europa
pero qué se puede decir sobre la
migración que se puede hablar de algo
que es así de amplio y así de complejo
podemos decir algo
entonces lo que nosotros decidimos hacer
en ese momento fue justamente partir
como de las preguntas plantean no de
decir ok quizás no tenemos muchas
verdades pero si podemos preguntarnos y
nos pareció como algo muy honesto para
hacer en este minuto y así surgieron las
primeras preguntas
nótese el naranjo
qué significa migrar que es migrar en
mover ser más es cambiarse de un país a
otro es vivir en otro lugar por cuánto
tiempo
quienes son los migrantes somos todos
los que vamos a vivir a otro lado
emigrante o son algunos migrantes y
otros no que se siente emigrar
como nos interpela a los que recibimos
qué pasa con la otra cara de la moneda
que pasa cuando llegan personas a vivir
a tu lugar qué pasa con la identidad
también desde ese punto
cómo cambia la experiencia migratoria
dependiendo de cómo actúe el que recibe
qué pasa si es que a mí me reciben bien
oa mí me reciben mal cambie mi
experiencia
qué pasa con las raíces con lo que
nosotros llamamos hogar al hogar
y finalmente también qué es lo que
ocurre con la identidad del que mira
cómo se construye la identidad
la identidad la construyó a partir de mi
propia imagen o la construye a partir de
la imagen que otros tienen de mí y quedo
de aproximación nosotros podríamos tener
desde el arte que era el lugar que
habíamos elegido para hablar sobre este
tema
entonces lo que nosotros decidimos hacer
con todas estas preguntas y algunas
ideas la cabeza fue comenzar nuestra
compañía siempre se ha caracterizado por
hablar de a partir de las historias
personales de quiénes son sus
protagonistas en el fondo lo que
nosotros hacemos en el teatro es algo
que se llama bio drama con algunas
características de lo documental que
pone en escena a los protagonistas que
relatan sus historias eso por una parte
crea algo interesante en el teatro que
es el arte de la representación porque
él juega con lo eliminar entre mostrar y
representar entre la realidad y la
ficción y eso a mí me parece muy
atractivo pero además cuando se ponen en
escena historias que hablan de la
contingencia cuando esas historias
encarnan fenómenos que de otra manera
quedan en cifras en datos o que quedan
en imágenes que se esparcen por el
internet entonces se convierten en una
herramienta importante para hacernos
reflexionar y también para permitir
encontrarnos
entonces lo primero que teníamos que
hacer era buscar a nuestros
protagonistas y para eso hicimos un
casting
bueno hicimos un casting y quedó nuestro
elenco al principio fueron seis y luego
por distintas circunstancias nos
tuvieron que dejar dos
ángel y más noche y así quedaron
nuestros protagonistas mal haitiano
caída española mayra que es boliviana y
la el y que era ya parte de la compañía
que es argentina y judía y a ese equipo
se unieron otras personas que fueron muy
importantes en el camino la laura
mestres diseñadora eduardo víctor y
daniel y con ellos empezamos un periodo
de laboratorio que duró alrededor de
tres meses
creo que al comienzo de todo nuestro
proyecto para mí por lo menos una clave
de la tuve un encuentro que tuvimos con
la socióloga veronica correa que en ese
momento no estaba asesorando en la
investigación del proyecto ella nos
contó que trabajando con mujeres
latinoamericanas migrantes en chile-
investigando sobre ese tema se había
dado cuenta que en general se construían
en torno a esas mujeres muchos discursos
que a veces incluso se ocupaban como
elementos de aceptación de la migración
pero que eran discursos que finalmente
eran generalistas y que también
estereotipada en la experiencia de ella
y dejaban atrás muchas cosas que tenían
que ver con sus motivaciones personales
para migrar por ejemplo existe como una
imagen generalizado de la que uno ve
bastante también que tiene que ver con
mujeres latinoamericanas de países
cercanos al nuestro como de perú o de
bolivia que vienen a trabajar a chile
dejando familia e hijos para trabajar de
sol a sol y poder recolectar ingresos
que les permitan llevar a sus hogares
sin dejar de lado con la verdad que
tiene eso y que efectivamente una
realidad muy habitual lo que yo nos
planteaba es que aproximarnos hacia la
historia de esas mujeres sólo desde ese
lugar nos impedía mirar otras
motivaciones que ellas también habían
tenido para migrar ellas habían migrado
y otras mujeres no entonces cuáles eran
esas motivaciones por ejemplo querer
desarrollarse en un área o querer
conocer un lugar nuevo en el fondo
habían otras cosas que tenían que ver
más con sus intereses propios y eso me
pareció interesante por lo menos a mí yo
creo que por varias razones primero que
nada porque muchas veces detrás de esos
discursos que son generales existen
estos dos estereotipos también que
simplifican la realidad
adapta a la realidad lo que nosotros
esperamos que suceda a la expectativa
que yo espero que ella cumpla al migrar
pero esas expectativas son
simplificaciones y porque lo hacemos
porque de otro modo tenemos que mirar la
complejidad de la experiencia y la
complejidad es incierta y la
incertidumbre nos incomoda o nos amenaza
entonces muchas veces preferimos
escuchar de que la gente viene a
trabajar porque su país está mal pero
nos cuesta mucho más aceptar una
emigración que tiene que ver con que
alguien quiere moverse de un lugar para
otro armas
como si esos deseos que son los nuestros
propios que nos llevan a buscar otras
cosas que nos llevan a irnos a otro país
o a cruzar una frontera no fueran lo
suficientemente importantes como para
que nosotros podamos aceptar que alguien
quiere ejercer su derecho a moverse de
un lugar a otro por ese motivo y además
que eso afecta particularmente algunas
personas y otros no pareciera ser que
hay gente que no puede optar a eso que
tiene que venir a trabajar o que tiene
que venir porque del otro lado nos queda
un espacio que es ambiguo por otro lado
también porque eso esconde otras
discriminaciones
del tipo ellos quieren hacer todos los
trabajos que nadie más quiere hacer
quizás quizás la gente no quiere hacer
todos los trabajos que más quiere hacer
pero una manera de que eso cumpla las
expectativas que nosotros tenemos un
lugar donde queremos poner esa
experiencia yo creo que también el
tercer punto fue que nos hizo nosotros
se relacionó con otra pregunta que
también teníamos mucho que tiene que ver
porque tenemos como miedo a enfrentarnos
aquí que no conocemos hay un miedo a
aceptar al otro porque sí por qué y de
dónde viene ese miedo es intrínseco es
algo que aprendimos de dónde viene
con todas estas cosas empezamos un
periodo de laboratorio como les conté
que duró alrededor de tres meses y ese
tiempo hicimos todo lo posible por
conocernos
vamos a alguna fotito
estamos por conversar conversar de los
relatos de cada uno de
y de los motivos que han inspirado la
avería de cada uno porque porque
estábamos porque estaban aquí cuál era
las cosas que nos hacían similares cuál
eran las cosas que nos hacían diferentes
de los juegos de cada país de las
comidas típicas y también conversamos
respecto de cosas que muchas veces
parecen ser comunes o parecen ser
visiones como normalizadas sobre ciertos
temas pero que en verdad no lo son como
por ejemplo que es ser limpio que es
para mí ser limpio que es para otra
personas en limpio en esta que le mostré
antes
estamos justo haciendo eso catalogando
no quiere daba el limpio que no se
entiende por ser bonito o feo
y con todas esas cosas armamos un
montaje que estaba compuesto justamente
de cápsulas que hablaban sobre la
experiencia migratoria nuestros cuatro
protagonistas y con eso estrenamos
visite nuestro sitio
esas son imágenes de la primera
temporada que tuvimos hace casi un año
y ahora empezó a su perfil
hay algo muy potente en la historia
personal entonces yo creo que y resonó
bastante en el público también y en la
crítica para salir bien y nos han
invitado a distintos festivales a españa
como a brasil hemos estado en el norte
de chile
pero en algún momento también hacia el
final de esta primera temporada de hecho
tuvimos nos encontramos con una mala
crítica con una crítica mala de frentón
sobre nuestro trabajo
y nosotros durante todo el proceso en el
cual estuvimos como hablando
investigando e investigando
conociéndonos
como creadores
nos planteamos mucho el evitar ir a un
lugar que fuera paternalista que mostrar
a los migrantes como pobrecitos que
merecían nuestra ayuda y que había que
cambiar la imagen
pero justamente esta crítica en algún
lugar apuntaba un poco a eso como que
nos tildaba un poco de paternalistas con
esto imaginar la herida luego qué es eso
ahora ya trabajando mucho tiempo reverte
llega algo pésimo
pero yo creo que después de pasar un
poco del dolor
esta crítica igual de nuevo nos hizo
reflexionar sobre varias cosas primero
yo creo sobre cuál era nuestro rol como
creadores y como también la mirada que
nosotros tuviéramos era algo que estaba
siendo reflejado en escena como nosotros
desde nuestros lugares estábamos también
imponiendo una visión que estaba dentro
de la obra
y que esa visión a veces quizá era
crítica personas que pensaban distinto
que nosotros también
podemos escaparnos de eso
se puede no tener un discurso
o quizá mejor trasparentando
entonces en ese momento lo que nosotros
optamos fue por justamente hacer eso
tratar de transparentar cuál era nuestro
rol de carlos y mío como director en ese
momento sobre lo que estaba ocurriendo y
como nuestra mirada también está
permeada en eso yo creo que eso también
nos hizo tomar con más fuerza un hilo
conductor que ya veníamos planteando a
lo largo de la obra y que es la última
pregunta que yo les quiero dejar hoy día
que tenía que ver con justamente
con una crítica también que nosotros
teníamos y que tenía que ver contra
aparentar un poco lo que nosotros
pensábamos respecto que tiene y que se
vinculaba con
quien califica para migrar y quién no
porque algunos pueden migrar y otros no
porque creemos que algunos tienen el
derecho a migrar y otros no
de acuerdo a las naciones unidas el 14
por ciento de la población mundial micro
de un lugar a otro alguna vez en su vida
eso quiere decir que 1 de cada 7 de las
personas que estamos hoy día aquí fue es
o es migrante uno de cada siete somos no
más desde el principio de nuestro tiempo
mucho antes de ser sentar yo de hecho
las naciones de estado como los
conocemos y díaz son relativamente
nuevas si miramos la historia la
humanidad
las tecnologías la globalización no ha
permitido crear cada vez con más fuerza
comunidades que no dependen del
territorio entonces por qué seguimos
poniéndonos fronteras porque seguimos
gastando esas fronteras a los lugares de
donde nacimos
yo con esto no quiero ser inocente
evidentemente que cuando aumenta la
población en un lugar de un momento a
otro de manera pronunciada se produce
miles de cosas hay temas que tienen que
ver con los servicios públicos hay cosas
que se relacionan por ejemplo con
distintas tradiciones que pueden tocar
pero la manera que tenemos de resolver
eso es calificando los
puede venir si es que tienes educación
puedes venir si es que tienes cierto
nivel de ingreso puedes venir si es que
tienes cierta edad puede medir si es que
tienen un registro impecable queremos
que lleguen los mejores que los mismos
que decir no califica si es que eres
pobre no califica si es que no tienes
educación no califica si es que eres
viejo no califica si es que tu país es
un país de segunda categoría
el teatro no es la realidad
el teatro no puede ser la realidad
tampoco
no le podemos pedir al arte que tampoco
sea una política pública con esta obra
probablemente nosotros podemos alivianar
poco la realidad de las personas que
emigran y que efectivamente lo están
pasando mal
tampoco podemos resolver los problemas
de los servicios públicos pero el teatro
de un lugar sensible es un lugar desde
donde nosotros podemos hablar en donde
podemos provocar dónde podemos pensar es
una manera que tenemos para repensar la
sociedad
para moldearla como queremos como dice
ver tu empleo
real la manera caída él y ellos no
pueden reflejar toda la realidad de lo
que significa el ser migrante yo tampoco
les puedo pedir eso como ponemos en la
obra ellos desde algún lugar también
muestran una cara un poco más bonita de
la migración ellos fueron los
privilegiados ellos pueden estar ahí en
ese montaje con todos los altos y bajos
que sus días también tienen no son la
cara más terrible de la migración hay
una cara que es mucho más oscura que es
mucho más triste que es mucho más sola
una cara que ni siquiera puede estar
quizás en una obra de teatro
pero es la cara que nosotros como equipo
decidimos mostrar porque esa experiencia
que quizás son más brillantes y otras
que quizás son más oscuras también
tienen matices y son lindas y son fea y
son triste y son felices y son solas
pero también forman hogares en otros
lugares ya se comunidades
y detrás de la migración de haití
también está raro y detrás del conflicto
con el mar y bolivia también esta manera
para terminar les quiero dejar una
última frase también de estiman andan
gogh se ha dicho
que dice lo siguiente
es el momento de replantearnos
el momento de replantearnos cómo
pensamos los relatos la cuestión de los
derechos humanos no hace referencia sólo
a las grandes historias de represión
trata también de los relatos íntimos
encontrarnos con el relato del otro
donde dejan de ser los cristianos y
comienza a ser real o johann flor vil
donde deja de ser el conflicto entre
chile y bolivia y comienza a ser mayra
es probablemente una de las maneras más
sensibles y directas que tenemos de
enfrentar los cambios que hoy día
nuestro país y el mundo exterior también
muchas gracias marianistas un gran
aplauso
[Música]